what's up about the marvelous let mrs.
Maysville people really love this show
is you're not me they're doing some you
know lots of different TV shows try
different ways of promoting yes you know
the show
especially around Emmy season marvelous
mrs. mantle did a real interesting thing
they in a select area is this correct
yeah selector and select stores yeah
everything was for sale at nineteen
fifty-nine prices that's right correct
that is when the right to in
neighborhoods that aren't looking for a
bargain base
Pacific Palisades right right but it's
sort of it I sort of yeah yeah right
exactly a bargain where nobody needs it
no yeah we're Emmys voters are but it
was a wonderful thing what a day
yeah give me an example of I mean yeah
were you there and first of all 1959
prices that could cause like a huge
problem it's certain place they had just
shut down a gas station they were giving
they were well how much for the gas like
10 cents then you can literally pull up
at a gas station in the late 50s and
throw up like a dollar to throw two
pennies they would fill your tank yes
you didn't they would okay so they had
to shut it down because I like a lot of
people observing you and at arts deli
here in Studio City they were 25 cents
sandwiches and there was a line down
Ventura Boulevard right and I was at my
dry cleaner in Studio City and there was
a line at McConnell's this wonderful ice
cream store and I thought I wonder if
this is an amazing day thing so I
thought I'd give everybody a treat and
there's a line and I walked down the
line and nobody recognized I got to the
front of the line and there's the Mazal
balloons everything and I went oh and I
walked back to my car and no no
Jane I will tell you is it is it is a
rule in the universe that any time a
celebrity says watch this thank you for
a thrill it's not going to go it always
happens that way watch this everyone's
gonna love getting a load of the
overhead hand quit sir
and then you walk in yeah they're like
who is that woman we have a clip here
from the marvelous mrs. Mazal and I
believe this is where well you can set
it up better the night yeah this is a
telephone like the Jerry Lewis telethon
it's on for 24 hours and I play Sophie
Lynn and I'm like the biggest comic star
in in 1959 and so midge is also a rising
comedian and she's got a spot on this as
well but basically it's a raising money
for arthritis and it's it's basically
about these poor arthritis sufferers and
there's a telethon for them and that's I
think this is when you're performing in
this yes okay here we go this is a clip
from the marvelous mrs. Mazal sorry
folks
you're gonna see also get a little
emotional right now
[Applause]
what a great show I mean the Wardrobe
the set yeah be fun to be in yeah to
have it be a period show like that 59
and they do it's so beautiful all right
well the marvelous mrs. Mazal season 3
premieres December 6th on Amazon Prime
video and best of luck to you at the
Emmys we're rooting for you thank you so
what I'm saying that knowing that I may
be talking to someone who's running
against you in a week on the show and
I'll say we're rooting for because I'm a
soulless [ __ ] Hey
[Applause]